hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich bin mal wieder auf tour
und zwar bin ich jetzt gerade einstieg
messe das ist so eine ausbildungsmesse
oder besser gesagt die größte
ausbildungsmesse in karlsruhe und der in
der dm-arena der messe karlsruhe
und ich stehe jetzt hier wir sind jetzt
direkt vor dem youtube hoch sag ich
jetzt einfach mal und zwar kommen jetzt
heute ganz viele leute her die sich über
ihren ausbildungsplatz kümmern oder ein
praktikumsplatz suchen und ich bin jetzt
heute mit hier
denn ich habe euch ja schon mal gesagt
dass ich gerne ein paar berufe einfach
vorstellen möchte aus dem karlsruher
bereich und einfach so gewisse
berufsfelder eben erklären möchte
und da suche ich jetzt einfach noch ein
paar leute die mich dabei unterstützen
jemand der witzig ist und jemand der
einfach wissbegierig ist und so gehen
wir dann auf tour und stellen einfach
verschiedene berufe vor
und jetzt dürfen die leute praktisch
hierher kommen und sich hier in dieser
box vorstellen es ist also eine youtube
box wo wir dann hinter der kulisse
fragen stellen und die das eben
beantworten um das ganze ist ziemlich
lustig man hier auch recht schräge vögel
heute dabei waren so richtig lustige
typen und ich glaube ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal ein paar ausschnitte
und dann komme ich gleich wieder zurück
doch die freude der gäste führten
charakter
wenn es aber seit zwei jahren gegen den
kopf aber ich finds nicht nur immer
weiter
ich gebe nicht auf ich finds auch für
jede andere die auch wegen ihrer
kopplung weltweit kein ausbildung findet
einfach nicht aufgeben weitermachen
ich habe den schon seit monaten glaub
ich traurig hierbei wir das natürlich
gut verlief könnte sich vorstellen die
auf tour zu gehen und verschiedenen jobs
vorzustellen ja auf jeden fall ich habs
jetzt schon ein paar mal live getroffen
und das hat mir super lustig mit er und
hat richtig spaß gemacht und es wird
total gut gefallen
jetzt habt ihr einfach mal so einen
kleinen einblick bekommt was jetzt alles
heute so passiert ist und wer alles da
war wohl ihr könnt euch auch gerne mal
die einzelnen clips zu den leuten die
jetzt hier vor der kamera standen auf
doping baden.de anschaut da kann man
sich jeden clip einzeln anschauen
man kann kommentieren und bewerten und
ich würde es einfach mal sagen ihr
schaut da rein lasst mir aber auch den
kommentar da und es gibt auch eine
youtube seite von job in baden an so
dass ich auch im youtube kanal und ich
verlinke euch einfach an meine infos in
meiner infobox unten unter dem video
dann könnte alles noch mal nachlesen
und lass mich einfach wissen wie ihr
dieses video fandet und vor allem wer
der beste fahrer cover bis zum nächsten
mal